[Music]
on this Tuesday night unjustified and
unreasonable the Court ruling on the
federal government's use of the
emergencies act it was the right thing
to do ottawa's next move the Israeli
military's deadliest day in Gaza how 21
soldiers were killed by their own
explosives preparing for the next
chapter in Canada US relations what
happens if Donald Trump wins again Mr
Trump uh represents a certain amount of
uh of
unpredictability plus a pivotal vote
what could be the last chance to stop
Trump from winning the Republican
nomination and the nominees
are Ken gets the Oscar nod but Barbie
gets the cold
shoulder global national with Don of
brezen good evening and thanks for
joining us we begin with a Court ruling
related to an unprecedented event in can
Canadian history the use of the
emergencies act to shut down protests
back in February of 2022 prime minister
Justin Trudeau's government invoked the
ACT to clear the streets of downtown
Ottawa for almost a month they'd been
taken over by so-called Freedom Convoy
protesters who had also blockaded some
border crossings today Canada's Federal
Court ruled using the Act was
unreasonable and unjustified
contradicting an earlier public inquiry
that found the government had acted
appropriately David Aken breaks down
what it means in our top story
tonight the Convoy protest had been in
Ottawa for 3 weeks and border crossings
in four provinces were being disrupted
that's when the federal cabinet invoked
the emergencies act for the first time
in doing so it gave law enforcement
agencies extraordinary powers to end the
protests but in the first Court ruling
of its kind Justice John Mosley sided
with civil liberties groups who argued
the government failed to meet a key test
before invoking the ACT Justice Mosley
in his decision today finds that
objectively the legal thresholds for
invoking the emergencies were not
emergencies act were not met the ruling
comes with no Financial Awards or
penalties the plaintiffs simply sought a
declaration that they were right and the
government was wrong the government on
the other hand still thinks it's right
and it will appeal the decision we were
convinced at the time I was convinced at
the time it was the right thing to do it
was the necessary thing to do another
judge Justice Paul Rulo agreed with the
government but ruo made his conclusion
not in a court of law but as a result of
the public order emergency commission
inquiry of late 2022 Rulo believed there
was a perceived threat to National
Security and the federal cabinet is
expected to reinforce that point in its
appeal of Mosley's ruling our national
security which includes our National
Economic Security was under threat
regardless of the appeal's success the
federal government had promised to
update the emergencies act for an era of
foreign interference and online threats
but the government has yet to make good
on that promise Donna David in Ottawa
thanks police in Edmonton say one man is
in custody after shots were fired and a
Molotov cocktail through inside
Edmonton's City Hall Global News cameras
were rolling on a city council meeting
at about 10:00 a.m. when it
happened manage parks and River that's
that close the doors close the doors
were locked um this surveillance video
shows a man who police described as
heavily armed walking into City Hall
with a gun and opening fire police say
it appears he was firing randomly and
not targeting people a police tactical
team responded and later said there was
no longer a threat to the public no
injuries have been reported no charges
have been laid and an investigation is
underway Americans are watching voting
in the New Hampshire primary tonight
polls closed not long ago and news
outlets such as the Associated Press and
NBC were quick to project former
president Donald Trump as the winner
beating former US ambassador to the UN
Nikki Haley setting Trump on the path to
being the Republican presidential
candidate Jackson prco is keeping an eye
on it in Concord New Hampshire Jackson
Trump has steamrolled over all his other
Rivals is Nikki Haley still in
it well Donna look it's no surprise that
Donald Trump won New Hampshire but what
is a surprise here is how narrow the
margin is Trump's team was projecting
projecting a 20 or 30 point spread here
it looks like it might only be single
digits separating the only two maor
major candidates left in the race and
that is good news for Nikki Haley who is
resisting any calls to drop out and
tonight she says she's in it to win it
pushing through to the next primary in
her home state of South Carolina and
through the campaign after that she says
she needs to to stick around to give
Republican voters some sort of
alternative to
Trump this race is far from over there
are dozens of States left to
go
let be heard and the next one is my
sweet state of South
Carolina so Jackson she is still upbeat
but can you help Canadians understand
why Donald Trump who we know faces
multiple legal battles who constantly
says false and misleading things who
attempted to overturn the results of the
presidential election that he lost why
he has such a lock on the Republican
party yeah I know it doesn't make a lot
of sense to of people looking in from
the outside and any other candidate in
Trump's predicament would probably be
considered way too damaged for voters to
even consider them that is not Donald
Trump though I mean his lock on the
party is Rock Solid I was speaking with
voters today who told me that they
recognize that Nikki Haley is probably
the better candidate to beat Joe Biden
but they just can't bring themselves to
turn away from Donald Trump in some
sense there's a cult of personality
around Donald Trump that just seems to
suck in everyone around him even people
who have their doubts and I think Donna
what we've seen here is that there is no
sense that people are willing to turn on
Trump there is polling out there that
suggests even if Trump is ultimately
convicted of one of these multiple
criminal offenses that his supporters
will still stand by him and even think
he could run the country from behind
bars yeah a lot to take in uh before
November's presidential election Jackson
frosco in Concord New Hampshire tonight
thanks
US President Joe Biden and vice
president kamla Harris had their first
joint appearance of the 2024 campaign
season they held an abortion rights
rally in Virginia Democrats are looking
to make abortion a key election issue
that they hope will Galvanize their
supporters after the Supreme Court
overturned Row versus Wade Canada is
also getting ready for the outcome of
the US presidential election and the
possibility of another Trump presidency
Canada US relations were at the top of
the agenda at the federal liberal
cabinet Retreat the Prime Minister
announced a so-called Team Canada
approach tapping key ministers to work
with Canada's ambassador to the US and
with Business Leaders to prepare for all
possible outcomes Abigail Beeman
explains cabinet on the road focused on
US Canada relations it was more candid
than I thought it would be car industry
executive Flavio vulpe was one of the
experts on stage I think we're better
prepared this time than we were before
we've shered ourselves of the idea that
you can check in when there's trouble
you should always be in contact vulpe
referring to when President Donald Trump
ripped up NAFTA the renegotiations that
followed strained Canada US relations as
well as the famous moment at the 2018 G7
hosted by Canada when Trump took off and
tweeted Trudeau was weak and dishonest
then backed out of the final agreement
obviously uh Mr Trump uh represents a
certain amount of uh of unpredictability
the Prime Minister announced a new team
Canada appr approach this is the team
who's done that before which should give
a lot of confidence to folks watching
there are literally millions of
Canadians and Americans who interact
together every day we want to engage
with them to understand what they're
hearing and then you know frankly deploy
Canadians to the US Justin Trudeau has
now been in power long enough to work
with three American presidents in the
event of a second Donald Trump
presidency I hear you speak to your
experience dealing with that
Administration so I'm wondering what
would you do differently a second time
around well worked best and what works
with all American presidents uh is to
demonstrate that what is good for Canada
is also good for the United States but
if that's the Diplomatic message
publicly behind closed doors the
Liberals are terrified frightened of the
idea of trump winning the election well
domestically this pocy prop says
liberals comparing the conservative
leader to Donald Trump isn't new the
difference is now
the Republicans aren't who they used to
be they're now way out there on the moon
somewhere under Trump we'll see just how
far the Liberals take that comparison as
they try to climb back in the poles The
Retreat here now done liberals will meet
with the broader caucus in Ottawa
starting Wednesday before the house
returns next week Donna all right
Abigail in Montreal thanks it has been a
terrible 24 hours in the Middle East
more than 24 Israeli soldiers have been
killed killed in Gaza along with almost
200 Palestinians as the Israeli Army
continues its assault on the southern
city of
[Music]
hunis there's been Fierce fighting in
that city which is crowded with
displaced people the IDF says it has
hanun encircled now gaza's Health
Ministry says at least 195 Palestinians
including women and children have been
killed in the past 24 hours and the
death toll since October 7th is now a
staggering 25
5,400 food is in such short supply the
UN estimates half a million Palestinians
are facing catastrophic hunger the head
of the UN today called it Collective
punishment Israeli soldiers are dying
too 21 of them in a single explosion
inside Gaza Danielle Hamin is in Israel
tonight with what we know about that
Danielle Donna for Israelis this was one
of the darkest days since October 7th
their soldiers killed by their own
explosives
[Music]
a funeral for one of 24 Israeli soldiers
killed in a single day Israel's
bloodiest day in Gaza since the War
Began all but three died in what the
Prime Minister called a disaster which
is now being investigated by the Israeli
military the troops were in southern
Gaza 600 m from the border they were
inside two buildings being prepared for
demolition where mines had been placed
by soldiers that's when a nearby Israeli
tank was hit by a rocket propelled
grenade possibly triggering an explosion
that caused the collapse of the
buildings we must learn the lessons and
do everything for the Peace of our
soldiers said Benjamin Netanyahu who's
under growing pressure at home to reach
a deal that will secure the Rel relase
of the hostages Hamas is still holding
more than a 100 Israelis captive some of
whom have been killed but their bodies
have yet to be returned my Israeli
government who I do not feel is doing
everything they can shooting will not
bring our hostages home alive we need a
deal whatever it takes that's what needs
to be done and deal with our other
problems later Hamas has reportedly
rejected a deal proposed by Israel on
the
an offer of a two-month ceasefire in
which hostages will be released in
exchange for Palestinian prisoners Hamas
leaders would have been able to relocate
to other countries but they refused to
leave and today Israel said it will not
agree to any deal that sees Hamas remain
in power Donna Danielle hamam Jin in hia
Israel thanks Danielle Russia is
stepping up its missile attacks on
Ukraine this time hitting the capital
keev and the second largest city City
harke at least seven people have been
killed a barrage of strikes damaged
whole blocks of apartments in harke
rescue workers searched the debris for
survivors and found an 8-year-old girl
[Music]
alive and in ke air raid sirens blared
for more than 2 and a half hours as
apartment buildings were targeted at
least 22 people were injured across
three districts there the UN says
today's bombard appears to have been the
heaviest since early
January NATO has signed a 1.2 billion
contract to buy more artillery rounds to
replenish the dwindling stocks of its
member countries as they Supply
ammunition to Ukraine to help it defeat
Russia delivery could take up to 36
months and after months of delays
turkey's Parliament has approved
Sweden's membership into NATO the move
clears the last big hurdle for Sweden to
join the military Alliance Hungary is
now Now set to become the only member
state that hasn't approved Sweden
joining prime minister Victor Orban says
he has invited Sweden's leader to visit
Hungary for
negotiations Iran has executed another
person who was sentenced to death for
participating in protests related to the
death of Masa amini 23-year-old Muhammad
aadu is the ninth protester to be
executed he was bipolar and appeals to
take his mental health into account
during the trial were rejected he was
accused of killing a police officer and
injuring five others by running them
over with his car at a rally Mass
demonstrations erupted across Iran and
around the world after amini's death in
September 2022 she was detained by
Iran's so-called morality police accused
of wearing her hijab improperly she
later died in
custody tragedy on a remote BC Mountain
coming up what's hampering rescue and
Recovery efforts after a hellis sking
crash
the coroner's office in the Northwest
Territories now says people have been
killed in the crash of a passenger plane
there this morning it's not saying how
many people or releasing any details
until next kin are notified the plane
reportedly lost contact shortly after
takeoff near Fort Smith that's about 740
kilom South of Yellow Knife the
Transportation safety board says the
aircraft is registered to a company
called Northwestern Air lease limited
it's capable of carrying 19 passengers
though there is no word on how many
people were on board the RCMP has sent
in search and rescue teams NBC a helis
ski trip has turned tragic three people
were killed four others badly injured
when their helicopter went down
yesterday afternoon the RCMP says it
crashed in remote terrain about 50 kmet
Northwest of Terrace BC the aircraft was
one of three helicopters on a
Backcountry ski trip it was operated by
Northern Escape helis skiing cassid
Moscone explains what more we know in
the remote mountain ranges of northern
BC tragedy three helicopters were
running a heli skiing operation in the
mountainous back country with numerous
people on board each helicopter uh
communication was lost with one
helicopter and a crash site was located
in a snowfield there were seven people
on board this helicopter and sadly three
people did not survive some 700
kilometers north of Vancouver
authorities in Terrace got the call
Monday afternoon then started the
complex search for survivors the two
other helicopters shuttled the remaining
four passengers from the site where they
were met by BC Ambulance Service Terrace
fire rescue and taken to hospital um the
injuries the victims had sustained were
considered serious through treacherous
terrain and freezing rain Tuesday's
recovery mission of the bodies of three
killed has been called off due to
weather conditions
two survivors are in critical condition
two are in serious condition the four
patients who are received at Mills
Memorial Hospital following uh
yesterday's tragic helicopter incident
have been transported now further um
South and BC for higher levels of care
Cassie Moscone Global News
Vancouver still ahead the lingering
safety concerns 10 years after 32 people
died in a Quebec Senior's
home
a somber ceremony is being held tonight
in the small community of Lil vert in
eastern Quebec it's to remember the 32
people who died when a fire ripped
through a senior's residence on a
bitterly cold night it happened 10 years
ago as Mike Armstrong reports time has
passed but for the people who live
through it the memories are vivid and
painful even though the plan was to
rebuild almost from day one it has taken
10 years construction is underway on a
new senior's residence for Lil after a
decade of delays it will be in the heart
of the community on the same lot where
the residance have once stood until
January 23rd
2014 the fire started at 12:20 a.m.
while residents were in bed it spread
quickly 20 residents were able to be
saved but 32 were
lost we met Fraser in the days after the
fire his mother had called him from her
room on the second floor of the
residence Fraser went with a ladder but
couldn't save
her he told us he couldn't get what he
had seen out of his
head 10 years later Fraser says time has
healed some wounds things hurt less but
that struggle with what he saw that
night
continues my family
Fraser says it's always there when he
closes his eyes in seconds he sees it
all
again the investigation Into the Fire
found the residents had smoke alarms but
no sprinkler system a coroner
recommended all institutions with more
than nine people should be forced to put
in sprinklers within 5 years the
government agreed but has repeatedly
pushed the deadline back 169 of Quebec's
1400 seniors residences are still not in
compliance but still have until December
nearly 11 years after the fire Mike
Armstrong Global News
Montreal and the nominees are next to
look at the Canadian talent up for an
[Music]
Oscar not everyone is ever happy when
the Oscar nominations come out
inevitably someone feels snubbed right
well let's start with who is Happy are
we saying there's a chance that when we
push that button we destroy the world
chances are near zero Oppenheimer about
building the atomic bomb got 13
nominations including best picture Best
Director best actor and best supporting
actor and actress director Christopher
Nolan saying today he never imagined
this level of success this is
Bella poor things about a young woman
brought back to life gets 11 nominations
killers of the flower Moon just behind
at 10 hey
Barbie can I come to your house tonight
sure and Barbie the movie that made the
most money in 2023 gets eight
nominations including best picture but
for a film that takes on the patriarchy
there were some glaring snubs director
Greta Gerwig and Margo Robbie who played
the lead
role just anywhere else
Ken however did make the cut Ryan
Gosling is among the many Canadians
being recognized this year he's up for
best supporting actor the guy flew 13
hours to be here I'm not going to tell
you that you can't see him or something
competing with those Hollywood
Blockbusters a debut from Canadian
Korean writer director sine song past
lives a love story partly based on
song's life gets best picture and best
original screenplay
nominations
and Canadian musician Robbie Robertson
who died last year is nominated for best
original score in killers of the flower
Moon I like to think he'd be happy about
that that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm Donna freezen tonight's your
Canada is Humber Valley near Corner
Brook New Finland and Labrador thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye